este vídeo ha sido posible gracias a
square space ya sean páginas web tiendas
online o herramientas de marketing y
analíticas es cual space es la
plataforma todo-en-uno para construir
una excelente presencia online y operar
tu negocio
[Aplausos]
[Música]
hay dos países en el mundo que siempre
se ponen como ejemplo de lo que no hay
que hacer dos países que durante mucho
tiempo pareció que iban a comerse el
mundo pero que sin embargo llevan
décadas viviendo una especie de crisis
crónica una crisis de la que no
consiguen escapar sabéis de qué países
os estoy hablando
uno desgraciadamente es argentina este
era fácil el otro a 18.000 kilómetros de
distancia
es japón aunque un momento por supuesto
esto no quiere decir que el dos países
sean iguales para nada es algo que hace
muy poquito vimos aquí en visual
político en un vídeo que os dejo abajo
en la descripción el caso de que cada
vez que un país desarrollado tiene
problemas japón es el país que se pone
siempre como ejemplo de lo que no hay
que hacer
[Música]
[Aplausos]
remedios de europa contra la
japonización el débil crecimiento y la
desaceleración de la inflación pueden
hacer que los europeos teman repetir los
errores de japón tal vez amigos la
persona que mejor ha experimentado esta
evolución tan negativa de japón durante
las últimas décadas ha sido precisamente
su emperador el emperador akihito
[Música]
cuándo
[Aplausos]
fatal
[Música]
me explico si el emperador en japón no
tiene poder pero lo cierto es que
akihito no ha tenido mucha suerte cuando
llegó al trono en 1989 japón parecía
comerse el mundo
[Música]
aquel mismo año de 1989 la compañía
japonesa sony entraba en hollywood por
la puerta grande comprando la columbia
pictures la división inmobiliaria de la
mitsubishi se hizo con el mismísimo
rockefeller center las inversiones de
las empresas japonesas estaban por todas
partes y las previsiones apuntaban a que
la economía nipona superaría incluso en
pocos años a la mismísima economía de
los eeuu
sin embargo en apenas tres años todo se
vino abajo la burbuja japonesa explotó
la bolsa de tokio se desplomó y la
crisis se extendió por todo el sistema
financiero japonés los años de fuerte
crecimiento económico se terminaron para
siempre comenzó una especie de caminata
por el desierto de más de dos décadas de
estancamiento económico
[Música]
desde 1991 el crecimiento económico
medio ha sido de apenas el 0 9% anual la
deuda pública pasó del 50 al 236 por
ciento del pib china al arrebato del
segundo puesto entre las mayores
economías del mundo las empresas
japonesas perdieron terreno y japón se
quedó prácticamente fuera de los
primeros puestos en la gran revolución
de internet
el coste las jornadas laborales
extenuantes de 12 y más horas siguen
siendo habituales los trabajadores
japoneses apenas disfrutan de 10 días de
vacaciones al año y los salarios reales
son incluso más bajos que hace tres
décadas y ahí no termina todo estos años
no solo han sido malos desde el punto de
vista económico también han sido muy
pero que muy convulsos en lo que a la
política se refiere
en estos 30 años japón ha tenido 17
primeros ministros de cinco partidos
políticos diferentes de locos
[Música]
amigos por si todo esto fuera poco
durante los años de akihito la población
también ha envejecido mucho y el país ha
conocido desastres como el tsunami y el
accidente nuclear de fukushima en 2011
por no hablar de la amenaza norcoreana
entendéis ahora por qué diantres decimos
que el emperador akihito no ha tenido
suerte ahora bien esperar un momento
junto al manga el sushi y los
carricoches para perros la crisis
japonesa es la cara que últimamente
siempre se muestra del país nipón pero
amigos acaso todo es malo en japón
qué pasa si os digo que a lo mejor las
cosas no han sido del todo tan negativas
como se cuentan y si de alguna forma
japón estuviera volviendo a brillar en
este vídeo aquí en visual político hemos
querido por una vez fijarnos en la mejor
cara del país nipón y también en una
revolución social que poco a poco de
forma sigilosa se está produciendo y que
puede suponer una referencia o al menos
todo un experimento para el resto del
mundo atentos
[Música]
la mejor cara
japón lleva tres décadas pasándolo mal
sumergido en una especie de
estancamiento o crisis crónica que no
consigue superar sin embargo a pesar de
ello sus números siguen siendo bastante
buenos
[Música]
es evidente que nos va a sorprender que
os diga que japón sigue siendo un país
muy rico eso lo sabemos todos pero la
pregunta es cuánto de rico o mejor dicho
cuánto de próspero sigue siendo el país
del sol naciente
[Música]
pues amigos podemos decir que japón
sigue siendo uno de los 20 países en
todo el mundo donde los hogares tienen
más ingresos después de pagar impuestos
con 28 mil 641 dólares netos japón está
a la altura de países como dinamarca
finlandia o los países bajos y por
encima de reino unido nueva zelanda o
irlanda
[Música]
y también es uno de los cinco o seis
países donde en promedio las familias
tienen más patrimonio financiero una vez
descontada sus deudas
[Música]
al mismo tiempo es el país con mayor
esperanza de vida uno de los países más
seguros a nivel educativo uno de los
mejores en el índice pisa es tan sólo
por detrás de singapur por su parte en y
más de en investigación y desarrollo con
más de 150 mil millones de dólares
invertidos cada año son el tercer país
con mayor nivel de gasto y el quinto
mayor en términos de pib tan sólo por
detrás de corea del sur israel suecia y
taiwán
y amigos aunque la deuda pública sea la
más alta del mundo ni más ni menos que
un 237 por ciento del pib realmente no
es algo tan grave como puede parecer a
simple vista
[Música]
el gobierno japonés tiene muchas deudas
sí pero también muchos activos
financieros de tal forma que la deuda
neta se reduce hasta aproximadamente el
150 por ciento claro no solo importa lo
que debes sino también lo que tienes
[Música]
y eso no es todo además el principal
acreedor del gobierno es el banco
central lo que en cierto modo quiere
decir que el coste de toda esa deuda ya
se ha repartido entre los japoneses
durante las últimas tres décadas por
ejemplo con menos rentabilidad
financiera con buena parte del capital
pasando a manos públicas por las compras
de activos del banco central y con menos
salarios reales en cualquier caso por
así decirlo toda la deuda está en manos
de los japoneses japón no tiene deuda
externa no es un deudor sino todo lo
contrario japón china y alemania-
principales acreedores del mundo japón
mantuvo su posición como la nación
acreedora más grande del mundo por
vigésimo segundo año consecutivo y a
diferencia de otros países de sus
empresas tampoco están enchufados a la
deuda
por ejemplo en la bolsa de tokio la
cuarta bolsa más grande del mundo seis
de cada diez empresas cotizadas no
tienen deuda neta
vaya visto de esa forma a pesar de todos
los problemas que el país tiene porque
los tiene las cosas ya no parecen tan
malas no creéis
[Música]
de hecho en los últimos años entre el
año 2007 y el año 2017 se ha producido
un efecto curioso fijaos la economía
japonesa apenas crece eso es un hecho
pero como su población se está
reduciendo y su economía no tiene
inflación el crecimiento real per cápita
que al fin y al cabo es lo que determina
el nivel de bienestar ha crecido al
nivel de eeuu y por encima de países
como francia o reino unido
[Música]
sorprendido en todo esto amigos ha
tenido mucho que ver la explosión
económica del continente asiático al fin
y al cabo japón tiene como vecinos a
países como china vietnam o la india
donde por ejemplo suzuki una compañía
automovilística japonesa acapara algo
más del 50 por ciento de todo el mercado
de coches de la india
estamos hablando de miles de millones de
consumidores potenciales
otro ejemplo fijaos en lo que ha
ocurrido con el turismo
[Música]
tradicionalmente japón ha sido un país
con pocos turistas claro estaban muy
lejos de los países desarrollados sin
embargo en los últimos años casi que se
está convirtiendo en todo un parque
temático japón es el país donde más
crece la llegada de turistas en todo el
mundo en poco tiempo gracias en gran
medida a los visitantes chinos el número
de turistas extranjeros ha pasado de
poco más de 6 millones en el año 2011 a
más de 31 31 millones en 2018 y ojo
porque las previsiones hablan de que
esta cifra podría superar los 60 60
millones para 2030
evidentemente todo esto supone un montón
de nuevos empleos pero su población es
la más envejecida del mundo y de hecho
se reduce cada año entonces cómo cubrir
todos esos nuevos trabajos amigos es
aquí donde entra en juego la revolución
social impulsada por el primer ministro
shinzo abe atentos porque japón se está
convirtiendo en todo un experimento
sobre cómo enfrentarse al envejecimiento
demográfico y creo que os va a
sorprender
la revolución social
vale en japón lo tienen claro en un país
tan envejecido que espera que su
población se contraiga fuertemente
durante las próximas décadas tan solo la
productividad y la inversión en
tecnología y robots les puede salvar
pero amigos eso es algo que lleva tiempo
y desde luego para poder invertir todo
lo que necesitan tienen que lograr ser
una economía próspera así que la
pregunta que todos podemos hacernos es
cómo puede una economía estancada
recuperarse y mantener controladas las
finanzas públicas mientras la población
envejece a toda velocidad con lo que eso
supone en pensiones y gasto sanitario
pues amigos si no cree que a corto plazo
es indispensable incrementar la
participación laboral el porcentaje de
las personas que trabajan que es
precisamente lo que está pasando en
japón
[Música]
pero os habéis dado cuenta como están
logrando incrementar el número de
trabajadores en un país donde la
población se está reduciendo y
envejeciendo a toda velocidad qué
diantres están haciendo en japón
pues amigos la respuesta es que en el
país nipón shinzo abe está liderando
toda una revolución social veréis por un
lado el gobierno está impulsando planes
para que las personas se jubilen más
tarde e incluso atentos para que los
jubilados vuelvan al trabajo
evidentemente a trabajos menos exigentes
y con turnos más cortos esto ha hecho
que ya más de la mitad de todos los
hombres japoneses de entre 65 y 70 años
estén trabajando más del doble del
promedio de los países de la ocde que
aglutina a casi todos los países más
desarrollados habéis visto la película
el becario de robert de niro pues algo
así que sí
[Música]
por otro lado el gobierno está
impulsando también un histórico
incremento de la participación laboral
femenina que en japón ha sido
tradicionalmente no muy alta japón está
viviendo una transformación enorme el
número de mujeres trabajando y ocupando
puestos de liderazgo está creciendo con
muchísima fuerza este cambio es
impulsado mediante lo que se ha conocido
como el women o mix una política que por
ejemplo ha incrementado los servicios de
guarderías incentivando los contratos a
tiempo parcial o alentado a las empresas
ajustar sus horarios a las necesidades
de las mujeres con hijos de esta forma
hoy japón es uno de los países donde un
mayor porcentaje de mujeres están
trabajando
pero amigos a pesar de todas estas
medidas la economía japonesa necesita
muchos más trabajadores de hecho hay
tantas vacantes que actualmente hay más
de 150 puestos de trabajo por cada 100
candidatos si lo habéis escuchado bien
hay más empleos disponibles que
candidatos muchos más por eso en los
últimos años shinzo abe está derribando
lo que hasta ahora ha sido todo un tabú
para la sociedad japonesa
[Música]
llegada de savia nueva
desde tiempos inmemoriales japón ha sido
uno de los países más cerrados a la
inmigración de todo el planeta
precisamente es algo que os hemos
contado hace ya un tiempo aquí en visual
político en japón la población
inmigrante apenas supone el 18 por
ciento del total el porcentaje más bajo
de todos los países desarrollados sin
embargo amigos eso ahora está cambiando
[Música]
japón asia
danos a tus jóvenes a tus trabajadores
cualificados a tus trabajadores ansiosos
desde que ave llegó al poder en el año
2012 el número de extranjeros se ha
duplicado y ahí no va a quedar todo en
diciembre del año 2018 japón aprobó
nuevas leyes para impulsar la llegada de
población inmigrante necesitamos
liberarnos del pensamiento convencional
crearé un japón que pueda atraer a
grandes talentos de todo el mundo sin
suave amigos las nuevas regulaciones
contemplan dos nuevos estatus para la
población extranjera por un lado un
estatus muy atractivo para atraer los
trabajadores más cualificados que podrán
instalarse en japón junto a sus familias
prácticamente de forma indefinida por
otro lado un nuevo estatus para que un
montón de industrias puedan traer a
trabajadores menos cualificados aquí las
condiciones son más limitadas pero aún
así la nueva
y busca acabar con todos los problemas y
las malas condiciones que estos
trabajadores extranjeros habitualmente
sufrían algo de lo que ya os hemos
hablado también en este otro vídeo
[Música]
bien en fin amigos si japón tiene muchos
muchísimos problemas os hemos hablado de
ellos ya un montón de veces y lo haremos
en el futuro pero también tiene motivos
para seguir siendo uno de los países más
ricos del mundo en que quedará esta
revolución social sólo el tiempo nos lo
dirá espero que este vídeo os haya
resultado interesante pero para terminar
dejadme que os hablé un poco sobre
square space quizás tengas la necesidad
de tener una web donde la gente pueda
encontrarte o quizás acabas de crear tu
propio negocio y necesitas empezar a
desarrollar tu presencia online o tu
propia tienda bien pues con square space
podrás llevarlo a cabo en square space
encontrarás plantillas para tu web con
diseños chulísimos o si a lo mejor no te
interesan las plantillas y tienes el
talento y la creatividad para diseñar tú
mismo tu web también puedes hacerlo por
tu cuenta
sin plantillas
square space hace súper fácil el poder
construir un espacio que resulte
increíble en square space puedes
registrar un dominio nuevo o también
mover uno que ya tengas el proceso es
súper sencillo y aunque todo es muy
sencillo si te surge cualquier duda es
qr space ofrece un servicio de atención
al cliente 24 horas donde encontrarás
siempre a alguien que te pueda ayudar lo
dicho si queréis tener vuestro propio
espacio vuestra tienda online lo que sea
haciendo realidad con square space veas
quest best puntocom para una prueba
gratuita y cuando tengas todo listo veas
cuál space.com barra visual polític s p
para ahorrarte un 10% al adquirir tu
primer website o dominio como siempre un
saludo y hasta la próxima
[Música]